[Music]
let's talk about
guns yes
oh wow oh [ __ ] those are
[ __ ] you're covering up your guns though
i don't really know sweatshirt you can
still see them they're pronounced true
true those are illegal you should have
seen them in a ball gown yesterday
i wasn't here yesterday now i'm curious
what the ball gown was i'm not wrong it
was a ball game
really you're wearing a
a ball gag with the ball gown yes
absolutely
you can't yeah i could do it for you
all right see you next time on jk news
patreon exclusive
geo is in the ball gag with a ball gown
you're in the ball gag with the ball
game
fine true what about what if we all have
ball gags on
oh i'm down except for the host and then
tiff would love it tim would be in
heaven yeah
oh yeah mushy yeah i guess so
all right so walmart is uh
thinking about pulling guns and ammo
from the store display
saw that this morning because of public
unrest my friend just shared it oh [ __ ]
so yeah it so bakery the election's
coming up
uh i don't know if this video is gonna
come up uh come out after before the
election
but uh if it you know but as of today
it's
we're like literally one two three four
four days five days
four days away from uh the election is
it november third or second
third yeah it's on tuesday but anyways
uh a lot of people are anticipating some
sort of civil unrest
uh regardless of who wins and uh
and like tensions with this whole
political thing has
you know not diminish whatsoever over
the course of the last four years
after covent toilet paper i'm getting
all kinds of [ __ ] before this
just because of that was crazy true i
stockpiled on beans they last a long
time
i have a police officer friend and then
uh their chief already told the whole
department whatever
family events you have planned for
november and thanksgiving just go ahead
and cancel everything
really everything like that and our
friend was like ha ha joke's on you i
ain't got family
yeah they're expecting it to be crazy so
they're like we just need everyone on
standby
yeah everyone in downtown like our
downtown right now like they're all
prepping
uh their shops like they're cutting up
boards oh really for riots
just in case yeah that's [ __ ] nuts
that's crazy yeah i was uh
i was on instagram i saw phil phil just
had his birthday
from wong fu oh cool no no happy
birthday
okay belated birthday sad birthday sad
birthday yeah but he was he was
celebrating and then
and but you know people were outside
like setting off
fireworks and like just in the street oh
man you know what maybe they were
celebrating because
it could have been it was the dodger way
interesting or something or his
idea was maybe they were just always
celebrating his birthday but point is
yeah like
la's l.a is uh a lot of wongfu fans in
l.a apparently
like the dodgers want yup you prick
you know i was totally wrong with that
you're right you're totally right
but yeah so walmart is thinking about
pulling off the guns and
pulling guns and ammunitions off the
sales floor uh
basically they're thinking you know
people might come in and steal it and
steal
and just start you know that's dangerous
i have guns at la walmart
though any walmarts in l.a yeah true
yeah
we don't they're talking about the other
ones right yeah across like fresno or
something
yeah across the nation yes yes whole
nation
it goes from here to fresno really yeah
that's pretty much it
so yeah walmart is actually uh one of
the major sellers of guns and ammunition
which i didn't know
but i just thought walmart was just a
retailer store but apparently a lot of
people go to walmart specifically for
guns and
not they got good prices and they got
good prices
dang so and roll back on this desert
eagle
it's cause they're so huge it's like
amazon that they can buy them in bulk
and they can sell it way cheaper than
everybo everybody else
so you get some good [ __ ] for like you
know a couple bucks off i got a cheap
amount of walmart yeah ammo's cheap
everything's cheap but it's never gone
to the to the
the gun side of walmart well the la ones
don't have the pencil
no even in texas like i just never gone
over there because like i don't know
like for me like as a kid i always
thought
guns were scary and bad so like i was
like near the gun area i was like
i'm gonna go to the brighton colorful
toy section over there peace out next to
the fishing area
yes it is yeah yeah i'm gonna drive my
buy my gun store after jk today and just
see if there's a line because that would
tell me a lot
there probably would be yeah because
pre-coveted just before they shut
everything down there was a line going
[ __ ] blocked
yeah every gun star is crazy they're
showing all over the news and there was
no ammo anywhere
yep that's why people just need to move
into mexican neighborhoods
true do you know the crate why what's in
there because what happens during like
protests and stuff
um mexicans they get the hot dogs ready
we know how to turn a profit they're
just like oh [ __ ] there's going to be
some civil unrest
well they're going to be hungry from all
that protesting right how much foot
traffic start [ __ ] getting all the
cars ready
really good every time i was out the
[ __ ] protest because i used to live
in downtown l.a right yeah
every single time there's like some kind
of like like
activism or whatever like like gay
rights or whatever right
there's a ton of mexicans just ready
with the bacon hot dogs sometimes
they're got them all in all right do you
think protesters like oh [ __ ]
i need to get cash first
they got [ __ ] uh yeah like what do
you call it cash actually oh yeah okay
they're just like yeah they're smart
[Laughter]
how much is that cactus
but yeah fun fact uh five million
americans bought a gun for the first
time in 2020.
whoa five million five million that
tells you how crazy 2020 is
like people that never had guns decided
that this was the year that they need
they need to have a in line with people
little
are against guns this is like the worst
nightmare year they probably are in line
now getting the gun
they're probably like oh [ __ ] i might
need it exactly no i know people who are
like
who have been the biggest anti-gun
people who are like i'm thinking about
getting again and i know 40
of that number is um first-time gun
buyers too
so almost half of it is the first time
they're just like i don't know what's
going on this year we need to go
and buy something i was in line with
those people because they couldn't
believe that you can't just walk into a
gun store and buy a gun immediately
and they were [ __ ] yelling at these
you kept here 10 days
yeah well no it's a 14 day wait from the
justice department even walmart's like
that
if you go to walmart california put your
name down yeah and then
and then ten days later you get these so
funny like the same people that are like
we need more [ __ ]
rules because people shouldn't be able
to just walk in and buy a gun
and then they go in and they can't just
walk in and buy a gun and they're like
what the [ __ ]
i need it now 10 days but the riots
happening now
i need it but you put these in you put
it in practice bro people are so [ __ ]
dumb
dude some like vice journalists did that
like a year ago they were like
you can't apparently you can't just walk
in and buy a gun and it's like no [ __ ]
people who buy who own guns know that
already and then the only people that
say
this lie are the politicians that are
trying to put more
restrictions on guns they lie to the
people and just say
yeah it shouldn't be uh a law it should
be against the law to just walk in and
[ __ ]
buy a gun whenever you want well maybe
they're going to certain places
because like you can go a lot of places
and just buy a gun
not legally that's illegal but yeah
there's a bunch of people who just got
done but some states you can also just
go and buy it too
oh there's a huge black market um
hunting rifles you'd is
not the same as a handgun in a lot of
places right yes
that's actually interesting that you
brought that up because i learned that
back in
the 90s at some point uh walmart was
they they actually stopped selling
handguns at walmart
so they only had hunting rifles and
rifles of
all sorts and then back in 2015 or
something like that they stopped selling
assault rifles or whatever and so they
there's a lot of
right i don't i don't know the
difference is yeah oh i'm like what the
[ __ ] is in a assault
ar is not an assault rifle there's
technically no assault rifles
for sale in the city rifles that have
been used for it's just
it's just like this okay so so this is
the difference right it's a
it's a it's a way of propaganda
so for example this is a sword
okay it's a saturday sword but it looks
scary
so it's a it's an assault sword
let's say you have uh another one right
same thing
same same mechanism same but it's it's
now
this is a historical display sword
it's different one's scarier than the
other one this one
it does the same [ __ ] thing and
that's so is that one not sharp no it's
really sharp
dude that's the issue with the whole
assault rifle thing
they're like oh no the hunting ones are
cool but these scary looking ones that
look
military style those are assault they do
the same exact thing
right they put a bullet into something
they function
similarly there's a magazine that you
can uh
load up into it like it's the same
semi-auto so you have to pull for each
trigger unless you got a bump stock
which they just outlawed so
but what is automatic is that when they
say okay now this is the bad guy this is
the assault yeah but uh
automatic rifles are illegal yeah they
haven't been they banned
in the 80s yeah yeah in the 80s yeah
yeah
some of the arguments i hear then are um
uh
yes those are banned but then they're
like well why do you need such firepower
like because some of these have like
different like the bullets will do
x amount of damage depending on the size
of the bullet
because i don't know you
i don't know how strong this dude is
what are you talking about i don't know
somebody's
not trying to break into my house and i
don't know them but that's like some
questions like that to me it's
you're not looking for a solution you're
looking for an argument to be right
because it's almost like why do you need
more than 10 gallons of gas on your car
why does it have to be 20 gallons right
you're just like arguing the
hypothetical now you know right because
they
they can't fathom the idea of like well
you might have
five guys that come in to do a home
invasion robbery
right and they're like well i have 10
bullets that's
two bullets per person i don't need more
than that it's like how do you [ __ ]
know if you don't train
how do you [ __ ] know if you don't
even trained people miss
shots right or like there's so many
different things where
it's based off of people who don't know
[ __ ] about what they're talking about
it's like if i don't know how a car
works if i don't really know how to
drive that well
why am i why am i gonna make laws about
cars and i think those arguments of like
oh why
why can't we just have the little
bullets and why do you have the big
bullets
those are coming from people who have no
[ __ ] clue of
how this mechanism works or or whatever
you should have a flintlock rifle that
you have to [ __ ] put the
because that's what they said when they
were doing the constitution or the
hunting ones are completely fine the
hunting ones are okay but like the ones
that are
scary and assault like you said during a
home invasion which by the way happens
all the [ __ ] time especially during
cove
they've gone up and many people have
successfully defended themselves
using these weapons that we're talking
about yeah these scary ar
evacuations but that's what sucks right
is that we have these
politicians who kind of pander to this
group of
people and and they fear monger and they
do a disservice because
they basically play with stupid they're
not even talking about
guns in the way where it should be
talked about
they're just kind of spreading fear but
this is what you decide how they should
be talked about
because okay so you said it's people who
just don't know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about
what if it's people who are just against
death where it's like
have a gun if you feel like you need
protection someone's breaking in your
house
fire in the air they run away that's
what people think why do you need to
[ __ ] murder everybody who broke into
your house
what if they were just trying to steal
some [ __ ] and they weren't trying to
murder you
but i don't know that that's not my
argument right i'm asking the question
right right you're totally right you're
absolutely sure is true i mean but i
don't know that that's my whole argument
i don't know
i actually agree with the idea of less
force right
like if you could use martial arts to
take somebody down
for sure if you can use um like the last
resort
is going to be murder but how do you
know they're there to take [ __ ] and not
to rape your life
that's the whole thing so that's the
point is that they don't show up and go
yeah this is what i'm going to do right
now just let you know so it's
unrealistic because the people who are
throwing these hypotheticals they've
never been in dangerous situations
they've never
trained in any type of combat they don't
understand any of these things because
these questions don't come from people
who's been in war law enforcement
any type of aggressive and violent
situation because
they come from minds of people who can't
even understand violence
they'll be like well if he's just coming
in to like steal your [ __ ] you could be
like yeah go ahead take it
but like what are you gonna do you don't
even have the minute to be like
hey are you gonna yo we're cool right
like you're not gonna stab me like
i know you got a knife in your hand but
like yo you could just take this
how do you know that that guy's not on
[ __ ] crack and he's like you're a
demon and i'm going to cut your throat i
don't care about your money
you know that guy's not having his wife
dying and he needs somebody to call and
there's nobody
you never you don't know anything so i
think people are like
why is that the solution when it could
be
this or this or this and when it comes
to the [ __ ]
ar-15s and [ __ ] like that where you're
just sweeping the [ __ ]
that's not it's not sweeping a
[ __ ] though because when you
have an ar-15
you have to pull you don't you can't
just hold the trigger down it goes
like that it just doesn't work like that
so it's not i think the actual solution
that most
like people that support the second
amendment what they're trying to
advocate for
is you just being responsible for your
own safety
yeah that's all they're really that's
that's so for them i agree yeah so for
them it's like
if uh if someone comes in statistics
show that
neighborhoods that are more armed
there's just less crime
because people know you can't really
[ __ ] around here in the neighborhoods
where there's a
hell of gun control but there's a lot of
crime because people [ __ ] around a lot
so i think that's why people target old
people yeah so i think for them they're
just saying like
being responsible like for your own
safety
it's the worst case scenario if you have
to shoot a bad guy down
but at the end of the day your safety is
still in your own hands if you have to
and if you must
that's the thought process no i mean i
definitely get i feel that way too like
i'm i'm definitely not
against guns i feel like everybody
should [ __ ] have one because of what
you said yeah and it should be open
carry so they know
i got this [ __ ] leave me wrong you know
what i'm saying but
at the same time it's like there's so
many instances of people
not taking down a bad guy yeah they were
in a bad mood
yeah not the guy that got killed yeah
the guy with the gun
you know i'm saying [ __ ] like that so
it's like i
get why there is even an argument i just
feel like nobody's taking the time to
think of an
actual solution that's why i'm for
background checks
background checks 14 but that doesn't
mean [ __ ] well no of course not if not
for first-time offenders but at least we
could do a better job of
but you can be a person who's never done
anything
now you have a gun and somebody's been
pissing you off
and you just have a bad day like you
become an option now yeah
it becomes obvious what do you do though
there is no there is no minority report
dude we need [ __ ] psychics who are
figuring out who's going to be doing it
before it happens that's why they
don't have a strikeforce if there's
going to be a protest and crazy riots by
protests turning into riots
they showed us that we'd be doing this
with their hands though and like screens
they're cool
that's why it's one of those topics in
just our culture specifically
that's so complicated because it's not
just one thing
like it's not just for hunting it's not
just for self-protection
it's not just for um because we have the
right of a
assembled militia in case of a
tyrannical government
there's multiple reasons and there's
different purposes right
it might be for defense it might be a
way of life like someone who's in the
hills who needs a gun
in order to hunt so because he needs his
protein and they don't go to the market
you know what i mean like there's so
many different reasons and there's
like um like even lifestyle culture like
in the
in the city we tend to be less gun
friendly because there's
the population is so dense and we don't
have space for all the rifles and [ __ ]
right and it's a different kind of like
lifestyle than being in the country
where like a gun is a good tool
well they also if you're calling the
cops in the country it's gonna take an
hour sometimes right and you don't you
got to protect your own
place and and there might be crazy guys
that are like just
doing road trip kill sprees you don't
know right so i think because it's so
complicated like that it's one of those
things where it's so difficult to
solve and it sucks because it's already
something
that we're born into like we born into
this society with
millions of [ __ ] guns out there
already 400 million yeah so when people
are just like just get rid of them it's
like shut the [ __ ] up united
stand get rid of the legal one exactly
yeah
and like just speaking i just uh just to
close out the video like speaking about
the person we're talking about like this
guy's just having a really bad day
and his gun is an option there's also
millions of other options
he can take a knife to his neighbor he
could drive his car through his
neighbor's
you know house so i think like for the
people that are advocating for guns
they're like it's never really the tool
it always has to start with the person
so that's why for them they're like
eliminating the gun doesn't do anything
foreign